your son is a teenager now yeah that's  what we have teenagers so go ahead I  think he's having sex now wasn't a  minute to me but I think he's having sex  the tell-tale bear because he just got  cooled all of us like its own about sex  that just smooth you right out you know  I would have disagreed until I saw a 40  year old virgin no no no no no he used  to be a nerd used to be like hey dad  let's go get some pizza and then one day  I went on a roll for two weeks and came  back outside let's go get some pizza and  he was like won't you bring me back a  slice I will not stop talking until you  subscribe to my youtube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this